[Music]
>> So hi, everybody.
My name is Kelly Huang.
I'm a program manager from Bing
Image Understanding team.
So today I will introduce Bing
Visual Search.
So visual search is a new
technique to looking for
information based on image or
acquiring a pattern image as a
query.
So in Bing, we have three
features.
The first is visual search.
Second is object detection.  And
third is image annotation.
So here are some pictures for
visual search.
We can support generic visual
research and we can also support
segment specific session, home
furnishings and people.
And here is our under-the-hood
visual search, like what are the
technicals behind them.  We
train DNN models for you and we
use optimized product
quantization for you.
So the second feature is object
detection.
This is not shipped yet but we
are shipping it soon.
So for object detection, the
priorities we support eight
categories for fashion.
As you can see, we show hotspot
here.
And you click the hotspot.  We
will draw the bounding box
automatically.
And after you draw the bounding
box, you will see there's a
product or these images here.
And here's another demo for the
home furnishings.
Currently we are working on a
training model for it.
So we use Faster-RCNN, which is
very popular in the industry, to
train the model, and we also use
our online GPU to support online
scenario, like users can input
any camera image to do object
detection.
And our latency is more than
100 milliseconds.
So last one is image annotation.
So why do we do image
annotation?
The intent is to predict the
content of image, like her photo
of her dog.
We can know which dog it is.
And with the flower, we can know
what flower it is.
And also we can know the
landmark, the food and the
celebrity.
So here are some examples.
Actually, we work on any generic
scenarios.
So this is our analytical image
annotation.
So we have two models, the
model-based annotation and
retrieval-based model
annotation.  Model-based means
we train the model and input
image.
Based on the model we can know
what category of the image.
This is the model-based, and
retrieval-based means we can use
any knowledge under Bing.
We have a huge index.
Then we can know -- for the
image we can know what is the
relative image query bounded to
this image, and then we know
annotations belong to those
similar images.
Then we can predict what is
annotation for those image.
So that's pretty much what we
have.
Thank you.